[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIJAY VENUGOPAL: Today was a
really exciting day for us.
Together with Google Cloud--
so Google, this
morning at the keynote,
announced the
availability of Anthos.
Anthos is a brand new
hybrid cloud platform--
hybrid Kubernetes platform.
And we think that
Anthos is going
to be a game changer
for the industry.
What I'm going to cover for
you over the next 50 minutes
or so--
I'm going to talk about what is
Cisco's partnership with Google
Cloud.
We've been working
for over two years
on developing on Kubernetes,
on Istio a bunch of open source
technologies.
And I'll talk about
what we've done together
to enable hybrid cloud
for our customers.
And I'll also talk in
more detail about Anthos
and how that integrates with
Cisco's product portfolio--
particularly on the data center,
the networking, the security.
So going into a little bit
of details about Cisco's
reference architecture
for Anthos.
I'm actually going to spend
some time doing a demo as well.
So I don't know how many of you
have attended a previous Anthos
sessions before--
I don't know if you've
actually seen a demo.
I'm actually going to do
a little bit of a demo
and show it live in action.
I also got a customer case
study-- a customer reference--
that I'll talk
about just briefly.
And then I'm going to pause
for questions at the end
if we have time.
I've got a lot of content
to cover in 50 minutes.
If I'm able to get
through it in time,
then I will take
questions at the end.
Otherwise I'm available--
many members of our team
are available-- here.
We're happy to stay back and
answer questions if we need to.
All right.
So without any delay,
let's get to the details.
So firstly the public cloud
adoption is a given, right.
Everyone-- 70% plus of customers
use public clouds today.
It's a big mandate
across the industry.
Everyone's adopting
the public cloud,
but everything is not moved.
Only 10% of the
workloads in the world
have actually moved to
the public cloud, which
means that still
90% of workloads
are running on the premise.
Not just that-- many of the
workloads that actually moved
have actually come back.
So about 80% of workloads that
migrated, for various reasons,
actually came back, because they
probably migrated too early.
What does that mean?
Right, what that means is that
on-premise clouds and hybrid
clouds are going
to be a reality.
And the entire
industry is realizing
that hybrid cloud is a reality.
And we all need to be able to
develop for the new future,
which is based on hybrid.
What customers are doing
is they run workloads
in the cloud when they need to.
They run workloads on
premise when they need to.
And what we as an
industry are trying to do
is make it easy for customers
to make that choice.
They can migrate
when they want to.
They can stay on prem
But we want to be able
to enable that choice
and let customers migrate
at their own pace.
Or if they choose
not to migrate--
if for security reasons
or compliance reasons,
they need to keep
things on premise,
we will help them and keep
things on premise as well.
So this is the vision that
we got together with Google--
and with Google Cloud.
And we've been working on
this for over two years
on a variety of technologies,
starting with Kubernetes
and hybrid Kubernetes with
Istio, which is a service mesh
technology-- again,
driven strongly by Google.
But Cisco is a big contributor.
And so we've been
working together
on some of these hybrid
technologies for over two
years.
But what we are really
excited to announce today
and really excited
to share today
is our partnership
extending to Anthos.
If the name Anthos
is new to you,
it was previously known as
a Cloud Services Platform.
And I'll describe what the
Cloud Services Platform is.
But this is a brand new
hybrid cloud solution,
announced by Google Cloud today.
And this is the
focus of my session--
what Cisco is doing,
specifically with Anthos.
So as a very quick
introduction-- what is Anthos?
I don't know how
many of you attended
the keynote in the morning
and saw the introduction.
But think of what Anthos
is trying to do is provide
a ubiquitous environment
across Google Cloud,
your on-premise environment,
and other public clouds--
a ubiquitous development
environment that's consistent,
that's secure, that's reliable.
And when you build
applications, you're
not developing for
an infrastructure.
You're not developing
for a cloud.
You're developing general
purpose applications
that are highly portable.
And what I'll show you today
is how we're able to build it
once-- developing it once--
and be able to migrate it to any
infrastructure of your choice--
or any cloud of your choice.
So this is game-changing, right?
The ability to write
applications-- write it once--
and without worrying
about portability,
without changing a
single line of code,
that same application can
now be run on any cloud.
So this is truly
enabling multi-cloud.
It's offered as a
managed service.
Google Cloud offers Anthos
as a managed service, which
means that you don't have
to worry about the software
lifecycle.
It's all managed-- the bits
are managed by Google Cloud.
So it's fully offered
as a managed service.
And it has full access to
the Google Cloud Marketplace.
It has full access to
Google Cloud Services.
And I'll go into more
detail on what that means.
But what this enables is a
true multi-cloud portability
for any customer looking to
do application modernization.
Application modernization is
the number one driving force
in the industry when customers
and developers are moving
from more traditional
applications
to more micro-service,
modernized applications.
And as they do
that modernization,
Google Cloud,
together with Cisco,
is making it easy for customers
to make that transition.
Let me double-click
a little bit more
into the Anthos architecture.
So first let's see--
the applications
are containerized
applications that run on
container infrastructure.
And the key element in
this is using Kubernetes
as the distribution-- as
the common infrastructure
platform--
or the orchestration layer to
manage the container lifecycle.
Now, the brand
new announcement--
today's announcement--
is that this container
platform-- the Kubernetes
platform-- is also going
to be available on-premise.
So you already had GKE, which is
available running in the cloud.
But now you've got the ability
to run the exact same GKE--
if you don't mind, could you
switch off your cell phone?
I don't think it's appropriate
to be talking on the phone
during the session.
Sorry about that.
So to continue where I left
off, the Kubernetes environment
was running GKE, which
was running in the cloud.
Now with Anthos, you have the
exact same GKE environment
that is now running on premise.
So an application that was
developed on Google Cloud
could be immutably transferred
or deployed in the premise.
So the application experience
looks exactly the same--
extremely consistent.
And on top of that, Google
Cloud is also providing
managed Istio services.
So those of you who are familiar
with Istio and the service
mesh--
what it allows you to
do is apply policies.
You have consistent policies--
consistent security policies--
for micro-services, needing to
access either other services
in the premise or
services in the cloud,
including Google Cloud Services
like Google Cloud Native
Services.
So the ability to do managed
IT policy-- managed security--
for a modern
application environment.
In addition to this,
Anthos also includes
monitoring capabilities to
provide seamless monitoring
across both the prem
environment as well as the cloud
environment.
And this is-- for
developers-- very
easy to monitor the health of
the application, the health
of the infrastructure,
completely consistent running
across both cloud and prem.
So this is the overview
of Anthos, right--
a managed platform
from Google that
allows you to do
application modernization.
This application-- it allows you
to do application modernization
in place.
So in the past, when you were
looking to do modernization,
typically you do the development
on Google Cloud or GKE.
But now if you don't even want
your developers-- if customers
don't want developers--
to develop on the cloud,
you can actually do entire
development in the premise.
But if you want to
develop in the cloud,
you can develop in the cloud
and deploy into the premise
or the other way around.
It's completely
seamless and secure,
unlocking developers
from worrying
about which cloud
you're running on
or which infrastructure
you're running on.
The choice of where
to run depends
on the policy set
by your enterprise--
by your customer,
your IT policy,
StackOps policy will
decide where you're run it.
But it unshackles
the developers,
because now you don't have to
worry about where it's running.
So it's write once,
deploy anywhere.
And all the security
capabilities
required by IT and
StackOps in order
to run in an
enterprise environment.
So just to summarize
the value proposition
both for IT ops, DevOps,
and for developers.
Really it's a
managed environment,
run on-prem or run in the cloud,
fully secure, fully portable,
supported by Google.
And this is the key value
proposition of Anthos.
Now what has Cisco being doing
together with Google Cloud?
So as customers are looking
to adopt a hybrid cloud,
there's a number of
challenges that block or deter
hybrid cloud adoption.
The first thing is that they
have existing data center
infrastructure, which
may be legacy data center
infrastructure.
There's a need to modernize
data center infrastructure.
The second thing
is the data center
is not a place in
the network anymore.
It's not a fixed location,
because increasingly,
with the adoption
of edge computing,
your T-type use cases
branch off as use cases.
The data center is
actually distributed.
Cisco likes to refer to it
as a data center anywhere,
or data center everywhere.
Because now you
take your compute
to where the data
is, because you
need to be able to process
data, without having
to transport large volumes
of data across low WAN links.
So there are use cases where
you need to do edge computing.
And so how do you
solve the challenge
when you need to do
edge computing at scale
and be able to run these
modernized applications
on them.
So there are some challenges
in evolving data center
requirements.
And really what
customers are looking for
is a private cloud or a
distributed private cloud.
Because now the private cloud
could be in one data center,
across multiple data centers,
or across edge locations.
And you need to have a
distributed private cloud,
which looks and feels
just like the public cloud
environment when you're
deploying applications.
We've talked about
security, and I'll
talk about one particular
use case with security.
Especially when it comes to
edge and branch locations,
having the ability to
have secure connectivity
between the edge to the
data center to the cloud--
and having ubiquitous
security across net.
And threat visibility across
this hybrid environment
is a challenge to solve as well.
And all of this
needs to be managed.
So what we've done,
together with Google Cloud,
is develop a reference
architecture for Anthos.
What that reference
architecture does
is it solves all of
these challenges that
deter hybrid cloud adoption.
So starting with a
private cloud stack,
based on Cisco
HyperFlex and Cisco ACI.
So Cisco HyperFlex
and ACI-- this
is part of the
market-leading product data
center, product portfolio,
that we've developed.
And for those of
you who don't know,
Cisco HyperFlex is a
hyper-converged infrastructure
platform-- a market-leading
hyper-converged platform,
available for several years now.
But what HyperFlex
allows you to do
is effectively build scalable
private clouds on premise.
It can scale up to very
large call data centers.
It can scale down to edge
locations or robo-locations--
IoT use cases.
So it's really a scale out,
hyper-converged architecture
that allows you to build
very efficient, very reliable
private clouds in the premise.
And ACI is Cisco's data
center SDN solution,
which gives you the ability
of doing network automation--
network provisioning--
at scale and having
the ability to automate
across multiple layers
of the networking stack.
underlay networking,
overlay networking,
container networking,
service mesh networking--
all these layers of
the networking stack.
You need a simple way
to be able to manage
different layers of networking.
And that's where ACI comes in.
So now this combination
of HyperFlex and ACI
gives you a very reliable,
scalable, simple, private cloud
for customers wanting
to run GKE on-premise.
The second is Cisco's
SD-WAN technology,
which allows customers
to securely extend
their environments, whether
it's a data center or branch
and be able to securely extend
that environment across VPNs
and be able to connect
into, for example, the VPC.
If you've got applications
running in the VPC,
being able to create
secure endpoints
in the cloud, which are VPN
extensions from the premise.
Cisco's Stealthwatch cloud
is, again, a leading solution
to be able to do threat
detection-- threat monitoring--
in a hybrid environment.
It natively integrates with
Google Cloud VPC Flow Logs,
so you can monitor traffic
patterns-- traffic attacks--
coming in the cloud
or in the prem
and actually give customers
the ability to monitor threats
across this hybrid environment.
And then Intersight a SaaS-based
infrastructure management
platform from Cisco
that allows customers
to manage this private cloud.
So together this combination--
this reference architecture--
of Cisco Data Center technology
with the Cisco networking
and security portfolio
combined with Anthos
gives a very simple
platform for customers
looking to adopt hybrid
cloud, making it easier
for them to build,
connect, protect, and scale
their hybrid cloud deployments.
So this is the overall
reference architecture.
Those of you who are taking
pictures, it's probably
a good time to take the
picture, because now the build
is complete.
So feel free to go ahead
and take pictures now.
All right, let's keep going.
So what does this mean
to you as customers?
As developers?
As customers, what
does this give you?
What are the benefits?
And what is the differentiation
that Cisco and Google
Cloud are developing together.
Number one-- we are focusing
on turnkey operations.
We want the whole experience
to bring up the infrastructure
to be really simple.
So what we are doing, working
together with Google Cloud,
is integrating Anthos into
Cisco's management platforms.
So when a customer wants to
bring up an instance of GKE
on prem, it's very simplified,
turnkey, validated,
out-of-the-box,
fully-integrated,
and it comes up.
And you can stand
up a cloud on prem
in a very, very short time.
Now, HyperFlex is a
data center solution
that integrates both
compute and storage
and software-defined storage,
software-defined computer
scale-out solution.
But it gives you an
enterprise-grade private cloud
platform, capable of providing
enterprise-grade compute
and storage services
to Kubernetes.
Even more specifically,
Kubernetes--
those of you who are familiar
with the storage architecture
of Kubernetes-- there is a newly
developed container storage
interface, or the CSI
interface for Kubernetes.
And what we're able
to do with HyperFlex
is provide that storage--
that CSI interface--
for persistent
volumes in Kubernetes,
running on our hyperconverged
infrastructure.
And that's what we're doing.
So what that allows you
to do in the platform is
enterprise-grade,
highly-resilient,
highly-clustered, and so now
when applications are running
on that, they're running
with full-resiliency
in an enterprise-grade,
hyperconverged platform.
And I mentioned, now,
networking a couple of times.
But again, this integrated
networking and security
into the platform, really gives
us an end-to-end architecture
for security.
And the entire
solution is jointly
integrated, jointly validated.
You will see reference designs--
reference architectures--
that are going to be published
by Cisco and Google Cloud.
And we are doing a lot
of product integration
in the backend.
And over the next few months,
you will see more and more
announcements that we're
going to make about further
integrations--
tighter integrations--
that we're doing to
create a really simple,
out-of-the-box cloud for
customers wanting to run
Kubernetes on prem.
Now, just a small
blurb on HyperFlex--
for those of you who are not
familiar with hyperconvergence
or with HyperFlex.
So just a brief product
pitch on what this is.
I won't spend too much
time on product pitches,
but just as an introduction.
Right, one of the
biggest challenges
with traditional
data center designs
is that it's highly
manual to operate
and very, very cumbersome
to build and operate
traditional data center designs.
And that's the reason
technology like hyperconvergence
has become extremely popular.
Because what
hyperconvergence does
is it basically integrates
compute, storage,
and networking into a seamless
software-defined platform,
which is very simple to
build, very simply to operate.
You don't need different
combinations of storage teams
or networking team.
It's all very simple.
It's all built on a
virtualized platform.
And it basically gives
you-- think of it
as a cloud in a box, right.
It's a cloud in a box
in a small environment.
And because of the clustered
nature of the architecture,
it can scale out.
It can start with something
as small as three nodes
in a cluster and
scale this out to 8,
16, 32, 64 nodes-- you can build
really, really large clusters.
And we've got customers
deploying this in hundreds
in large call data centers.
At the same time, we've
also developed technology
to be able to scale it
down to edge environments.
So it can run in branch
offices and IoT use cases.
I've got a very,
very interesting demo
that I want to
show you at the end
where we are going to use
HyperFlex running in a factory
floor, doing real-time
inferencing for machine
learning use cases-- an
industrial automation use
case, a very
interesting use case
that I'd like you to pay
attention to at the end.
And because of
this ability for us
to build this
ubiquitous architecture
that spans across the
data center, to the cloud,
to the edge.
We've redefined
the notion of what
we call the distributed cloud.
So now what you can think
of is a distributed cloud
for your modernized
applications-- for Kubernetes
applications-- and complete
freedom both for developers
and for the infrastructure
operators on whether you
want to run the app in the
cloud, in data centers,
or the edge.
But you've got a seamless,
ubiquitous architecture
that allows customers
to do all of these.
So just to summarize
the value proposition--
just a very simple one.
Very simple.
Very simple to operate,
highly reliable architecture.
And very importantly,
it does allow
the coexistence of what
analysts call Mode 1 and Mode 2.
Right, so Mode 1 refers to
traditional IT operations.
Typically these are running--
traditional
applications, running
in a virtualized environment.
Because customers are not--
you can't modernize
everything at one shot, right?
So you have-- typically
the databases are still
running in virtual machines.
They could be running
in traditional storage.
And you've got the ability to
have the web front-end start
to get modernized.
They get good.
They get containerized.
Then the application services
start to get containerized.
As everything
becomes distributed,
you have to have the
ability to coexist
existing, traditional
applications
with the more modernized,
containerized applications.
And what you're able to do
with this architecture--
with HyperFlex--
is you can actually
run them on the
same architecture,
the same environment.
So you don't have to do a
forklift upgrade of your data
center, and you can have
a seamless transition
between the traditional world
and the modernized application
world.
And like I said before--
highly scalable.
So it gives you the economics
of the cloud as well.
So you can build as
you grow, and you
pay as you grow for
those who are looking
to start small and evolve.
Again a very short pitch on ACI.
All I'm going to say--
ACI is Cisco's SDN technology.
And the main reason ACI is
important in the architecture
is because you've got multiple
layers of a networking stack,
right.
There's the physical
networking--
or the underlay networking.
You've got the
overlay networking.
And then in the
world of containers,
you've got the container
networking layer.
And then you've got
the service layer,
which is at the layer seven.
So if you have multiple software
stacks or multiple layers
of the network, troubleshooting
and monitoring and providing
visibility into
that is complicated.
And what we're
able to do with ACI
is give a single
networking stack
that's able to manage both the
physical, overlay container
networking and
service networking.
It can all be integrated
into one stack.
So when you need to
troubleshoot-- when things
go wrong, it's one
tool that you go
to to figure out how you
troubleshoot the environment.
So that's the reason technology
like ACI is really important--
because it allows you to
create that ubiquity, kind
of vertical network
stack, that allows
you to manage all layers of
the networking environment.
I don't know how many of you
are partners in the room.
But what we've been working
together with our partner--
with Google Cloud-- is create
very simple ability for managed
services--
MSIs, system integrators,
or technology partners--
to take this joint solution
that I referenced-- designs
available, blueprints available,
or that will be available.
And we'll take these and
allow customers to started.
So you have simple,
starter kits that
allow customers to get started.
If you want to actually go
and develop the data centers,
build the data centers,
develop applications,
partners can offer
services there.
And then we're able to implement
a broad set of services
for application
modernization as well.
So again, if there's any
partners-- channel partners,
system integration
partners-- in the room,
we're working to enable
for you as well how
to easily consume and pass
on the benefits to your end
customers.
I'm going to switch
gears a little bit now.
I talked about the technology.
Now I think this is the
more interesting part of it.
What does it really mean?
So I'm going to talk about
four different use cases.
And I've got demos for
two of these use cases.
So just pay attention
to some of these demos.
So the first one-- and the
first demo that I'll show you
is the ability to have
consistent operations
across the cloud and the prem.
The demo that I'm
going to show you
is how a single application
that's being developed,
available in the
GCP marketplace,
you can pick which cloud you
want to have that deployed to.
And without changing
anything, you
can just take that application
as it is and get it running.
And you have a seamless
customer experience--
a consistent experience
across the prem and the cloud.
Now, this ability to have
the seamless experience
also enables other
use cases for things
like if you want to use
DevOps in the cloud,
but you want to do
production in the premise.
So you can do the development--
so developers can build
in GKE, for example.
And then IT may have
an IT policy that says,
this application needs to
be deployed in the premise
for sovereignty are
security reasons.
And you can have
a simple IT policy
that allows you to do it.
But from a developer's
point of view,
he doesn't have
to change anything
when it's going into production,
because it is already IT ready.
It's already data center ready.
The third use case is one where
if there are services running
in the premise that need
access to cloud services that
are running in Google Cloud,
the Istio architecture actually
allows seamless connectivity--
secure connectivity--
between servers running in the
prem and Google Cloud Services.
So here's an example
of either Cloud ML
services or Big Data services
running in the cloud.
And you've got seamless
access to that.
So you unlock these.
So you can still be running--
the application could still
be running on the premise, but
you've got access to services
that are running in the cloud.
And the last one is where
we're talking about using
the power of edge computing.
And the second
demo that I'm going
to show you will be
around the edge computing
and how we can use
hybrid edge computing
architectures, using machine
learning as an example.
So I thought-- that's the
second demo that I'll do.
So I'll show your use case
one and use case four--
the two demos that I'm
going to be showing to you.
So to just describe-- and this
is the Anthos architecture
that I showed you
in the beginning.
But again, I'm just using
this as a reference.
So whether you use
Google CICP tools,
using Spinnaker to be
able to build and develop
your own applications,
all of these
are packaged applications,
available in the marketplace.
What this allows you to do
is you can have the ability
to deploy the application across
both the premise and the cloud.
And that is what I'm
going to show you next.
All right, so as
the demo kicks off--
I had to put this
into the video,
because if you show
the whole thing live,
it does take a
little bit of time.
So we put this into
video so we can actually
run you through the demo.
So to start the demo,
what we're going to start
is first we are going
to create Kubernetes
clusters on the
HyperFlex system,
running inside the premise.
And step two-- we're going to
register that cluster into GKE,
so you can actually view
and manage that GKE cluster
from GKE, even though
it's running on the prem.
So the first step
in the installation
is actually to get an
admin workstation running
in the prem.
And there's an install
process to which we get
the admin workstation running.
Once the admin workstation
is running inside the premise
environment, you just create
a cluster create command
from the admin console.
And what this is
showing right now
is that the cluster creation
completed in the background.
So now what we've
got is we've got
the cluster has been created,
running in the premise.
Second, you actually go to GKE.
So this is running
in the GKE console.
And what we're doing
over here is we're now
claiming that cluster into GKE.
So there's a two-factor
authentication.
You get the
authentication token,
you register that
cluster with the cloud.
You're going to give it
some tags, because it's
running in an RTP data center.
And you've given
it a HyperFlex tag
to signify that
this is HyperFlex.
And if you actually see
here, in GKE, in the console,
you're seeing a HyperFlex GKE
on-premise cluster, running
in a data center environment.
And you're seeing that side
by side with GKE clusters
running in a US west
region of Google Cloud.
So now in GKE,
what you've seen is
that you'll see both data
center clusters and cloud based
clusters are all running--
are viewed in one single
dashboard in your GKE view.
Now just to confirm
that this is indeed
running on the
premise environment,
you're going to do
a simple experiment.
We look at the nodes that
are running in the premise.
And we compare with the VMs that
are running in the HyperFlex
environment.
And you'll see that the
same worker of nodes that
were created in the premise--
there's a complete
match between that.
Just if there's any
skeptics in the room--
just to confirm that the
clusters and the VMs that
have been created by Anthos
and you're seeing in GKE
are the exact same
VMs and nodes.
These are Kubernetes
nodes, running
in a VM that is running on
the premise environment.
Let's go to the last
stage of the demo.
In the last stage of the
demo, what we're doing is
we're going to take a
packaged application-- just
to keep it simple.
We're going to take a packaged
application from the GKE
marketplace.
To keep it simple, we've
used Nginx as the example.
So we've taken an Nginx
from the GCP marketplace.
And we're going to deploy
an instance of Nginx
into the HyperFlex cluster
running in the premise.
So what you'll see in
the next few steps is,
when you go to the
marketplace and pick Nginx out
of the marketplace, we
can pick the cluster
to which you can deploy.
So either you can pick a cluster
that's running in the cloud
or pick the HyperFlex
cluster that
is the GKE on-prem cluster,
running in the premise.
Just change the namespace,
give it an instance ID,
and click Deploy.
And that's it.
You have taken a
standard application,
running in the
marketplace-- this
could be a CICP-based
custom application as well.
But it doesn't matter.
Once you've built
the application
and it's available in a
Kubernetes environment,
getting this deployed and
running on the premise
is a click of a button.
So this is where the
game-changing attribute
comes in.
Because now you've truly
enabled consistency
between the cloud and the prem.
Because without changing a bit--
without changing
a line of code--
you have created a
consistent environment
between the prem and the cloud.
And just to confirm, right,
so what we're doing now
is we've taken the external
IP of the Nginx system-- just
logged into that.
And you can see that
service is up and running.
And this is running.
It's an Nginx application.
It's not a simple example.
But basically what
we have shown is
how we are able to take
applications developed in GKE
and host that with
absolute simplicity
into a cluster that's
running on the premise.
So the demo was--
the video was-- probably running
a little too fast for you
to pay attention.
So let me just slow down
and repeat this again.
What you saw in the GKE
console was a set of clusters.
Some of those clusters were
running in GKE in the cloud.
running in a data center.
But it didn't matter
from GKE's point of view.
It didn't matter from the
application point of view.
Because now you can just
take the application
and just pick which
instance-- or which cluster--
where you want that running.
And it creates a completely
seamless environment
across both of them.
Now Anthos is also going to be
running on other public clouds
as well.
So now you can take
that same example,
and from the
marketplace, once you've
claimed the cluster
running anywhere,
you can deploy this on any
cloud, or on the premise,
or on the edge, or
in Google Cloud.
And it's completely seamless
from a developer and operations
point of view.
So this is really where we
think that this is opening up
game-changing possibilities
for our customers that
are looking to adopt
application modernization.
Now let's go into
the second demo.
All right, so in the case of
the second demo-- in this case,
let me explain the demo
context a little bit before we
go into details on this.
So the background here is
this is a bolts application.
Those of you who have
done any work on ML--
this is a standard
application that's
used to do a machine
learning demos.
But the problem
statement is this.
The problem statement is
this is a factory automation
environment.
It's an industrial plant.
And the industrial plant is
using a variety of bolts.
Now these bolts-- they
have different metrics.
They have different
measurement dimensions.
Right, they have the
standard dimension,
there's a metric dimension.
And to the visual
eye, you can hardly
tell the difference
between these two bolts.
But if you put the wrong
bolt into the machine,
it could stop production--
it could ruin the equipment.
So the ability to use the
right bolt in the right factory
automation-- industrial
automation-- workflow
is very important.
Now if you leave this to humans
to be able to visually detect,
it's really hard.
Because as you can see,
the difference between them
is very, very minuscule.
It's hard to tell the difference
between the two of them.
And so this is a
classic example where
you can do real-time machine
learning at the factory floor
in order to detect
the right bolt
and make sure that the
right bolt is used.
I'm just using the bolt
as an example, right.
There are many, many
more use cases that get
enabled to something like this.
But the point is that we are
using the power of machine
learning to be able to do
real-time image diagnosis
and use the image diagnosis
to solve a particular business
problem.
And in this particular
case-- in this demo--
what we are going
to show you is how
we are building a hybrid
machine learning use case.
So we have got data scientists
that have developed--
I think the next slide goes
into that in more detail.
So data scientists-- there's the
data sources that's available.
There's typically the
stream of images that's
available as a training data.
You've got to collect
and clean the data.
There's entire data pipeline
work that is required.
The data scientist then
develops the model.
There's training, and
then you develop a model.
At the end, when you need to
run real-time in inferencing,
that model does need to be
deployed into the premise--
not the premise,
that model needs
to be deployed wherever the
inferencing needs to happen.
In this particular case,
we've used an example where
the training and the
model development
happens in Google
Cloud, using Kubeflow,
and I'll describe Kubeflow
in a little bit more detail.
But the inferencing
actually happens
on a HyperFlex
edge system that's
sitting in the factory floor.
Now because of the real-time
nature of the inferencing,
it's very difficult. Because
as the factory production
line is moving--
as these equipment
and the bolts are
coming to the line,
the latency required
to process these means
that it's difficult to send
some of this transaction
over to the cloud or
to the data center.
So this is the reason.
So I talked about
some reasons why
customers may choose to
have workloads running
in the prem on the edge.
I talked about security.
I talked about sovereignty.
I talked about data gravity.
But latency is actually
a driving factor as well.
So when you have
applications that
require very low
latency access to data,
sometimes it's not possible
to move the workload back
to the cloud.
So it's a classic use case-- why
a combination of Cloud and Edge
is required to be able to
solve a customer problem.
Now what's the
technology behind this?
The technology behind this
is an open source project
called Kubeflow.
So Kubeflow is a project--
it's another project where
Cisco and Google have
collaborated very strongly.
We have contributed a lot.
We're the number two contributor
to Kubeflow after Google.
But what is Kubeflow?
Kubeflow is basically
an integration
of TensorFlow and Kubernetes.
It allows customers to
build TensorFlow models
and deploy them into Kubernetes.
In addition to the ability
to just run TensorFlow models
and Kubernetes, it
also has the ability
to manage data
pipelines as well.
Now again, I don't
know how many of you
are a data scientists or machine
learning engineers in the room,
but one of the
biggest challenges
you'll find that data scientists
are able to do the model
development.
It's relatively easy.
It's still time consuming.
You still need
time to develop it.
But once you develop the
model, deploying that
to where you need
the model to run
is actually a very
complex problem.
We've had customers
come and tell us
that it can take six
months or even a year
or sometimes to get the
models running efficiently
in the infrastructure the way
they need the model to run.
So this is the second
problem that Kubeflow solves.
Because it gives you the
ability to have these
reusable data pipelines.
And very simple capabilities
to be able to run these data
pipelines in a location
of your choice.
Right, so in this case,
what we're going to do
is we're going to show you how
we can run Kubeflow pipelines
and actually deploy it on
a HyperFlex edge cluster,
running Anthos, running GKE
on-prem on HyperFlex edge.
And we're able to deploy
these Kubeflow pipelines
into the edge.
So you can do real time
inferencing at the edge.
So I'll let the
video run and explain
what's going on
in the background
as the demo video is running.
So first, you're seeing
the model workflow
that you can see in Kubeflow.
Let's open up the
Jupyter notebook.
Right, the Jupyter
notebook, which is
used for the model development.
And it'll pull up
the Python code
that actually does
the-- the Kubeflow
pipelines are implemented in
Python code that is running.
In this case, the
model development
could happen in any
environment that supports
Kubernetes and Kubeflow.
So here's the Kubernetes--
the Kubeflow-- pipeline
for the bolt image
classification application
that has been developed.
The next step is
you actually stop
the process of doing
the model-- now
the model development
is complete.
And now you need to
deploy the model.
So now what it is showing
you, in the next few steps,
is how are models deployed
into the environment.
So basically,
there's a click Run.
And then you start
the deployment.
And you click Run on Kubeflow.
And basically what
it is doing now
is it starts the process
of deploying the Kubeflow--
the Kubeflow
pipeline is deployed
into the target environment.
So you can see that,
as the video plays,
the training is completed.
The deployment is going on.
And the services
to actually do--
when you say model
deployment, there
is a bunch of services
that need to be running.
And there's a bunch
of services that
gets spun up in order to
implement the implementation
of the inferencing workflow.
And so what you've
got now is-- now
you go to the
Kubeflow dashboard.
And you're able to
actually see the models.
And you see that the
TensorBoard, which is
the dashboard for TensorFlow.
And now once the
model is running,
we can do a quick and
inferencing test--
OK, give sample
images to the model.
And let's see if it does that
classification accurately.
Right?
So basically, what we have
done is, using Kubeflow,
the TensorFlow model
has been deployed
to the target environment.
And we are passing sample images
to see if the model is able
to detect-- in real time--
what the type of bolt was.
But where is this all running?
This entire
environment is running
on a GKE on-prem cluster
in a HyperFlex edge system.
So if you see over here--
you can see that the
bolt identification
model is actually running in a
HyperFlex GKE on-prem cluster,
running in the edge location.
And we are actually going
to go into Kubernetes
and start to look at the
actual services themselves.
So you're going to filter on the
services that are running here.
You're going to filter
for the services that
are running in that target
cluster that we picked,
which is a GKE OP cluster,
running on that HyperFlex edge
system.
And the video went a little
faster than I was speaking,
but what happened at the
end was that it actually
showed the running services--
all the TensorBoard
ML services that were
running as part of that model.
All of that was running
in an environment that
was running on an edge cluster.
So look at the power of
what we just showed here,
which is that from
a data scientist
or a ML developer point of view.
Now they can build their
training and their models.
And they use the tools
that are available,
which is time
consuming in itself.
But when they need to
pick the location where
the model needs to be deployed,
it's very, very simple.
So the power of
Anthos comes in here,
because what Anthos
is able to do
is give that same
consistent environment.
Because they're
running GKE on-prem--
they're running
GKE in the premise
and they're GKE in the cloud.
And both are running Kubeflow.
We've created a seamless,
hybrid development environment
for anyone looking
to do hybrid ML.
So we talked about the
promise of what this enables,
and hopefully some of
these demos do that.
And it shows you
what is possible now
when you have this seamless
or consistent development
environment that's available
both in the prem and the cloud.
I'm going to move over next
to a customer case study.
I'd like to talk about
a financial services
customer called Keybank.
So Keybank is a large financial
services organization.
They're headquartered
in the Midwest.
in the Midwest,
spreading their footprint
across 15 states--
1,100 branches, close
to 20,000 employees,
a fairly large financial
services corporation.
They offer a whole host
of financial services.
Now Keybank is one of the more--
I would say-- one of the more
forward-looking enterprises
in the world.
They've had a
DevOps team and they
started Kubernetes and
container development
over four years ago.
So they're one of the early
movers in this industry.
So they are, I would
say, thought leaders
when it comes to
Kubernetes adoption
and converting traditional.
You'd assume that the banks
and the financial services
are more averse to moving
to some of the modernization
technologies.
They've been doing it
for over four years.
So they've been using Kubernetes
for over four years right now.
And what Keybank did is they
have picked Anthos on HyperFlex
as their platform for deploying
their microservice applications
in the premise data centers.
Now because of
multiple reasons, they
need to have an environment
that's available on premise.
And first, they are big
Google Cloud customers.
So they do a lot of
development on Google Cloud.
They use GKE very heavily.
And they first wanted
to build an environment
where they can build
these applications
and run these applications
in the premise.
And one of the things that
Anthos gives this customers
is the ability to
monitor and check
the health of the application,
using the tools that we talked
about like StackDriver,
which allows you to monitor
the health of the application.
But the use case--
really, for them,
the reason why a
hybrid environment
is very important to
them is because they
want to be able to
burst to the cloud.
So when they build
their infrastructure,
they size it for average load.
But during peak
loads, they don't
want to build large data
centers to cater for peak load.
So they want to be able
to burst into the cloud
when they need to.
But the average load is running
in the data center environment.
So this kind of
seamless infrastructure,
where you have both the premise
environment and the cloud,
and you can burst into the
cloud without changing anything,
right.
So you can have
auto-scaling capabilities.
And with the auto
scaling capabilities
built into the app,
you can build the logic
in to say, just auto-scale this
into GCP during times of load,
which allows them to have
the seamless environment.
So it's another
use case of why it
is important to have a
uniform, consistent environment
across the board.
Now why did they pick
HyperFlex, right?
So the reason they
picked HyperFlex
was because they wanted a
simple, private cloud to be
able to run GKE on premise.
So they wanted it to be simple.
They wanted to have all of the
infrastructure capabilities
built into this platform--
very simple to install it.
In fact, its entire
POC was completed
in less than two weeks time.
We sent them a HyperFlex
cluster as an initial POC.
They brought up the HyperFlex
system in a few hours.
They deployed GKE on-prem
onto that cluster.
And they started migrating
their Kubernetes application
to this environment.
This POC has completed
successfully.
The speed at which
the POC completed
and the ease at which
they were able to do it--
it goes back to
some other things
that we said in
the past, which was
our goal is how
easy do we make it
for customers to be able
to build these cloud
environments on premise.
So it's a really
simple environment
to be able to bring
up these applications.
And of course, for
them, the reliability
was highly important
as well, right.
Because of the clustered nature
of the HyperFlex architecture,
where there is zero downtime.
Application upgrades can
happen without requiring
cluster downtime.
Infrastructure upgrades can
happen without requiring
cluster downtime.
You can do firmware upgrades.
You can do storage
upgrades-- all of that
while applications
continue to run.
So the ability to do
zero downtime upgrades
was extremely important.
So really, this is, again,
bringing one of those cloud
attributes to the premise.
Because now, this is a cloud,
and that doesn't go down.
Even if you're doing things
in the infrastructure,
the cluster always stays up.
Applications always stay up.
So it is a zero
downtime environment
for customers looking to get
that cloud experience on prem.
So this is a great
example of a customer that
went through the journey of
evaluating why did they want
a hybrid cloud architecture?
And why they picked Anthos
and HyperFlex as the platforms
to do hybrid cloud.
So to wrap up, what do you
need to do to get started?
To get started,
first of all, we've
got validated designs in
our reference architectures,
together with Cisco
and Google Cloud.
And these platforms have been
validated and been tested.
So you get validated
hardware-- or you will get,
once it's generally available.
In a few months, there's going
to be general availability.
And so you'll get all of this
available-- simple, seamless,
out-of-the-box.
And you can purchase
this either through Cisco
or you can purchase
it through Google.
You buy the Cisco
product from Cisco.
And you buy Anthos from Google.
And it'll be jointly
supported by Cisco
and Google technical support.
Right, so this is what
it takes to get started--
very simple for
you to get started
if you choose to and jointly
supported by both Cisco
and Google and Google Cloud.
If you're interested in
getting more information,
you can start with some
of the product URLs.
You've got URLs on
the Google website
as well as on the Cisco website
on how to get more information.
There's a training program.
There's a CSP-- or
Anthos-- training
program that's actually
scheduled for later this month.
Those of you who are
interested in getting
more hands-on experience,
there is a training program
that's available.
And then the series
of other trainings
that will be available.
And you can get started and get
your hands dirty with trying
on some of this new technology.
Just a very last bit--
this one is not directly
relevant to Anthos,
but Cisco also has a
number of other offers
that are available in the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
AppDynamics, which is our
application monitoring
solution.
Stealthwatch Cloud,
which I talked
about previously, which is our
trademark threat monitoring
solution.
And the Cloud Services
Router are all
available on the
Cisco marketplace.
And today, we also
announced the availability
of Webex, our collaboration
suite on the G Suite
marketplace as well.
So a whole host of other
things that Cisco and Google
are collaborating on.
Cisco and Google Cloud
are collaborating on--
when it comes to joint
technology, joint integration
between our companies.
So the last thing that
we'd like you to take away
is this joint solution between
Google Cloud and Cisco--
with Anthos and HyperFlex
and ACI and the other Cisco
technologies-- allows customers
to adopt the next generation
of hybrid cloud, which allows
developers to build once,
deploy anywhere--
complete freedom of where
the applications are running.
And this is jointly developed,
engineered, and supported
by Cisco and Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]